his series of what happened to national
liver
we heard yesterday some some ask some
things about what happened to National
Liberation and Michael talked about the
paradox of national liberation in India
Israel and Algeria and in particular
focused on pulling apart first exposing
and then beginning to pull apart the the
tension between aggressively secular
national liberation movements and what
was left in their in their path
dependent awake some years later and in
particular virulent challenges to the
very secularism that motivated those
movements and today he's going to I
think illustrate in more depth the
paradox and the many dimensions of it in
his second lecture called Zionism
against Judaism and just to preview next
week of course there'll be the third and
fourth of these lectures I did neglect
to say that the Stimson lectures are
co-sponsored by the Macmillan Center and
Yale University Press which will
eventually publish these lectures but
the so the third and fourth next week
same time same place will be on
Wednesday at 4:00 and Thursday at 4:00
but today we're going to listen to the
paradox Illustrated Zionism against
Judaism thank you
okay so this is as Ian said an effort to
illustrate the argument in some depth
and I will next week
consider a a rather tough critique of
the argument of my argument from a from
Marxist and post-colonial perspectives
and and then talk about what might lie
ahead for National Liberation Zionism is
one of the success stories of the 20th
century national liberation movements
the first generation of Zionist leaders
proposed the solution to the Jewish
Question that seemed to just about every
realistic Jew and non-jew in the world
impossible to realize and the next
generation realized that the realization
came too late for most of the Jews of
Europe it was it is darkened by the
greatest catastrophe in Jewish history
nonetheless Zionism reached the
unreachable goal the Theodor Herzl set
for it within the 50 year time span that
he envisioned the Zionist movement
established the sovereign state in which
Jewish self-determination impossible for
almost 2,000 years is now an everyday
fact so why isn't that the end of the
story everything after is post Zionist
what we should talk about now is
Palestinian national liberation but the
Zionist story is more complicated than
that brief telling suggests and it is
complicated in much the same way as the
victories of the Indian National
Congress and the Algerian FLN the
Zionist project isn't entirely a success
and it hasn't reached its end what I
called in my first lecture the paradox
of national liberation has its
specifically Jewish version
which is my subject today imagine that a
group of the zionist founders found
themselves in contemporary israel a
ghostly congress discussing the history
of the of the movement most of the
people attending i think wouldn't
believe that their project had been
fully realized the state as it is today
would not match their visions even the
political Zionists who were often said
to want nothing but a state any state
anywhere had in fact a particular state
in mind and Israel isn't quite that kind
of state it also isn't the kind of state
that the Mizrahi rabbis the small number
of Orthodox rabbis who supported the
Zionist movement it isn't the kind of
state that that they had in mind but I'm
going to focus on the expectations and
disappointments of the others because
Zionism was at its center and in the
years of its greatest achievements
overwhelmingly a secular project that's
what makes its relation to Judaism so
interesting I propose to look closely at
that relationship taking it as a special
case of a tension or a contradiction
that could be illustrated also in the
histories of India and Algeria and since
this further case is bound to come up in
the case of Palestine to which even
before statehood has its own history of
secular nationalism and religious
revival the Jewish version of the story
begins with exile over some 2,000 years
a span of time that our imaginations
cannot easily encompass the stateless
and scattered people of Israel developed
a religious political culture that was
adapted to statelessness and scattered
miss I don't know how long it takes to
develop a culture of that kind we can
find signs of the adaptation very early
on but the social construction of exile
as the prototypical Jewish condition
took many centuries and the construction
is very powerful this is the deep
architecture of Jewish life Judaism as
it existed in the late 19th century when
Zionism was born was a religion of exile
a yearning for return to the long-lost
homeland played an important part in
that religion the idea of political
independence played no part at all the
Jewish people have forgotten wrote Leo
Pinsker and his pamphlet is the early
Zionists pamphlet Auto emancipation the
Jewish people have forgotten what
political independence is exilic
politics had only two aspects first Jews
submitted to Gentile rule they practiced
the politics of deference and second
they waited patiently for divine
redemption they practice the politics of
deferred Hope in fact there's a lot more
to say about the actual political
experience of the Jews but it is only
this dualism that is reflected in their
law and literature Jewish submission
would last until the coming of the
Messiah and the coming of the Messiah
was in God's hands and seemed to be
indefinitely postponed deference and
deferment the words and practices that
this politics required had to be
reinvented in each diaspora setting but
this was in no sense a makeshift
invention nor would it be right to say
that it was reluctantly accepted it was
indeed the natural politics of the Jews
in the eyes of the Jews themselves the
necessary consequence so it was commonly
thought of the place that God had
assigned them in world history it
follows then that any political effort
to escape from the Exile any nationalism
aiming at statehood and
sovereignty would have to be the work of
people who rejected this divine
assignment who broke with the culture of
deference and deferment but since this
culture was a central part of Judaism as
it existed in the 19th century Zionism
was and could only be the creation of
people who were hostile to Judaism if
pressed I will qualify that remark in
various ways but in its naked form
unqualified it helps to explain a
centrally important Zionist goal the
negation of the Exile
the negation of the Exile this is not
the same as the end of the Exile of
course Zionists wanted to bring the eggs
out to an end but they also believed or
many of them believed that it would be
impossible to do that without first
negating the cultural predispositions
and habits the mentality of the Exile it
was necessary to overcome the long term
adaptation of the Jews to their
captivity among the Gentiles and the
name of that adaptation was Judaism this
overcoming could find support within the
Jewish world but its most prominent and
successful advocates were likely to be
Jews who had assimilated into the world
of their oppressors and who viewed their
own people with a foreign eye
Herzl was a nationalist leader of
exactly that kind who wanted the Jews to
have a state like any European state the
Zionists dream of normality is born out
of persecution and fear but it also has
two intellectual sources both of them at
odds with exilic culture the first is a
close-up knowledge of the other nations
and the second is the belief that
imitation of those others is both
possible and desirable Herzl indeed
imitated the most progressive European
ideas especially with regard to
status of women an issue I spoke about
last time in his Zionist utopia the old
new land
published in 1902 women have equal
rights with men and are obligated like
men exactly like men to do two years of
national service Harold isn't explicitly
set this equality against traditional
Judaism's exclusion of women from all
public roles but it's an obvious
challenge to the tradition leaders like
Herzl or max Nordau his most prominent
intellectual supporter have few
anxieties about the negation of the
Exile because nothing in their
experience suggests that there is value
in what is being negated they have no
sentimental ties to the old way of life
and this may be the key to their
effectiveness
they are single-minded in pursuit of
their goals but the same alienation from
the people they mean to rescue can also
bring down the leaders of a national
liberation movement as the Uganda
episode suggests in Harold's case I
can't tell that story here but it's
probably sufficiently well known so that
I can discuss it very briefly it began
in 1903 when a British colonial official
suggested that a large tract of
territory in East Africa what is now
Uganda might be made available for
Jewish settlement in lieu of Palestine
instead of Palestine hair soluz eager to
accept the offer which represented the
first official recognition of the
Zionist movement as a territorial
claimant he apparently had little sense
of the opposition it would arouse
Zionist leaders closer to their people
understood immediately instinctively
that this was negation gone one step too
far
however desperate the condition of the
Jews
and the Uganda debate unfolded
immediately after the Kishinev pogrom in
in Russia however desperate the
condition of the Jews a specifically
Jewish nationalism could have only one
country as its object the Land of Israel
these leaders who opposed the Uganda
project most of them Russians wanted to
acknowledge the British offer with
gratitude and then reject it which is
what happened three or four years later
after Herzl's
death in a curious way the idea of
settling Jews and Uganda under British
rule was simultaneously too radical and
too conservative its radicalism appealed
to some secularists and socialist
Zionists who worried that the mystique
of the Land of Israel would make the
work of cultural transformation more
difficult or perhaps defeated entirely
their argument was forcefully stated in
a way that resonates today by Hillel
Zeitlin who said the same tradition that
burdens us in the Diaspora will burden
us a thousand times more in the Land of
Israel because that is its home the
rabbinic dominion over the masses will
not be weakened there as the
free-thinking Zionists hope but on the
contrary we'll get stronger and stronger
Uganda or at least the idea of Uganda
offered a new beginning a chance to
establish national life on a modern
footing at the same time however Ugandan
settlement would also be a continuation
of the exile and the subjection it
entails the new rulers would certainly
be more benign than the old the king of
Israel the King of England the King of
England was far preferable to the
Russian czar or the turkish sultan but
he was not King David he did not
represent Jewish sovereignty and that
may be why the Mizrahi
rabbis were so comfortable with Harold's
scheme they would not have to face the
challenge of sovereignty at one of the
earliest Zionist meetings the Cata wits
conference in 1884 an Orthodox delegate
from Romania argued against political
independence for reasons that may seem
trivial to contemporary secular Jews and
non-jews but in fact go to the heart of
the conflict between Zionism and Judaism
no state he said can maintain itself
without a postal service railways and
the Telegraph and these have to be
operated day and night throughout the
week but I'm quoting now if the
officials of Israel were to rest on the
Sabbath according to the laws of Moses
other states would protest while if we
were to permit our officials to violate
the Sabbath and the festivals our
brethren would rise up and destroy us
and that says nothing about the
maintenance of gas and soon electricity
services firefighting the police the
ordinary functioning of hospitals and
clinics and much else in the lands of
the exile all this necessary work was
done on the Sabbath by Gentiles in
Uganda the British presumably would
arrange for it to be done it was not yet
imaginable to religious Jews that they
could do it themselves in their private
lives they relied on a figure called the
Shabbos [ __ ] a Gentile friend or neighbor
or servant who performed all the
necessary chores forbidden to Jews on
the Sabbath and what was the state what
else could it be in pre messianic times
but a large-scale Shabbos [ __ ] I doubt
that Herzl ever worried about the
possible incompatibility of the laws of
Moses and a Jewish state his visionary
description of a state where as he said
the army stayed in its barracks and the
rabbi's in their synagogues did not
include
laws from a political standpoint the
sacred geography of the Jews should have
worried him more but he had little sense
of that either until vo get Uganda
controversy erupted accounts of his
conversations with British officials
suggests that he argued for as much
autonomy as he could get in a Ugandan
setting the setting itself was of less
importance to him and yet sacred
geography was one feature of exilic
culture that as it turned out neither he
nor any of the other Ugandan 's later
they called themselves territorial ist's
could negate the cultural Zionists
followers of Occam opposed the Uganda
plan and sharply criticized hair cells
lack of Jewish culture and learning even
more his insensitivity to Jewish
emotional attachments they regularly
insisted on the need for continuity with
the past and a few of them like the poet
Khayyam Nachman Bialik aimed consciously
at a critical engagement with rather
than a negation of the Exile the Alex
call for a cultural in gathering
alongside or even before the demographic
in gathering suggests the road not
taken' which I will want to defend later
on as the better path a calm himself
sharply attacked Zionist riders who
understood the whole of Jewish history
as he said to be one long mistake that
requires immediate complete
rectification though he acknowledged in
a private letter that Zionism may
involve a latent contradiction with
Judaism deep within the soul he
consistently opposed what he called
defiant apostasy nonetheless his own
ideas about continuity were selectively
focused mainly on prophetic morality and
the ideas of many of his followers and
admirers were more selective
still zionism wrote Leo Motzkin is in no
sense a direct continuation of the
ancient culture even though it means to
refashion something rather than create
something ex nihilo argued Joseph
Klausner Zionism is a highly radical
Jewish movement it aspires to a total
revolution in Jewish life to a revolt
against the Diaspora and the chief
object of that revolt was religion
itself though some of the some of the
rebels would have said that they were
opposed only to its decadent exilic
forms in Martin boobers words to the
subjugated spirituality in the imposed
tradition drained of its meaning like
uber many of the cultural Zionists and
later the Socialists too looked for
inspiration to biblical Israel here was
a culture of Kings warriors and prophets
that they could hope to continue but the
biblical heroes as they were described
in Zionist literature and propaganda
seemed to be the exact opposites of
contemporary Jews and their Creed was
very far from contemporary Judaism it
nourished strong men and women whereas
the religion of Exile in Zionist size
produced political passivity and
resignation a slave mentality that was
incapable of resistance or self-help to
turn to the Bible was to acknowledge or
break a cultural chasm it is not in our
power declared Israel Kagan a leading
Orthodox rabbi as if an illustration of
the Zionist thesis it is not in our
power to repair the condition of our
people because we are under the
domination of our enemies statements
like that were taken by Zionist writers
to represent the lack of national
self-respect and self-confidence of
political initiative and unity
produced by years of exile and religious
resignation but Kagan would have said
the domination was God's decree and that
there were other sources of self-respect
than political strength the gap between
these views was very wide and it wasn't
easy to find continuity sometimes the
zionist critique was less doctrinal and
more immediate as when writers mostly
very young attacked the turning away
from physical activity and from the
natural world that marked exilic life
indeed the anti-semitic stereotype of
the pale stooped Jew is also a Zionist
stereotype and Zionist writers had no
difficulty identifying physical and
mental weakness stoop backs and warped
Minds those warped minds and the
specifically intellectual qualities bred
by centuries of subjection frequently
provoked Zionist anger okata i'm railed
against i'm quoting now the lack of
unity and order the lack of common sense
and social cohesion the narcissism that
holds such terrible sway over the
prominent members of the people the
thrill of showing off and the arrogance
the tendency always to be too clever
this kind of diatribe has many
counterparts in other nationalist and
revolutionary movements i cannot resist
the comparison possibly unfair to akka
dom with Lenin's critique of russian
intellectuals he charges them with
Slaven leanness carelessness untied eNOS
unpunctuality nervous haste the
inclination to substitute discussion for
action talk for work the inclination to
undertake everything under the Sun
without finishing anything the list of
complaints is is different but the tone
is very much the same and I don't think
that these two men for all their
differences
would have had much difficulty agreeing
on what they disliked in their
contemporaries
so Zionism was marked simultaneously by
a deep commitment to the Jewish people
and by an equally deep commitment to the
transformation of the Jews these
youngsters wrote aaron Eisenberg a
moderate religious nationalism these
youngsters are frantically opposed to
our traditions which have been
sanctified by the people and yet they
claim that everything they are doing is
intended to save the people and some of
them even say that the people cannot be
saved unless they the youngsters first
destroy everything the people have built
with their blood destroyed and saved
saved but destroyed let me illustrate
this the transformation these militants
hoped for with a list of contrasting
pairs of cultural values and attitudes
which might be labeled from and to
passivity activity fearfulness courage
deference pride obedience rebellion
weakness strength indoors outdoors
peddlers and shopkeepers farmers and
workers subordination of women gender
equality dependence independence
subjection citizenship isolation from
the world engagement with the world fear
and hatred of the Gentiles equality and
friendship with them I can't deal with
all these contrasts and perhaps I don't
have to
since the paired items form a coherent
and more or less self-explanatory whole
many Jewish intellectuals and
professionals in the West believed that
the transformation represented by the
second term in each of the pairs
required only emancipation civic
equality in the lands of the Exile Jews
would become British or French or German
citizens and then lead normal
lives they would be liberated as it were
in place they would leave the ghetto but
not the Diaspora and then they would be
active proud strong and so on and if
they weren't the reasons would be
individual reasons as with their Gentile
neighbors the cultural Zionists thought
this belief and illusion but they also
more importantly thought it was a
typically exilic illusion another sign
of the loss of self-respect emancipation
was simply the latest version of
subjection a new way to defer to the
Gentiles typically it did not require a
critique of religious belief it was
perfectly compatible with the faith of
Moses as this had been defined by the
rabbis but it did require the surrender
of any claim to national
self-determination Alcott ha sa slavery
in freedom is a bitter critique of
Western jewelry which had sold its
heritage in his view for meager and
purely private advantage at the same
time the clothes narrow vulnerable and
frightened world of Orthodoxy in the
east the most visible form of the
heritage was no better it represented
slavery in slavery Zionism aimed at an
escape from both this required
collective action cultural and political
in character but assimilated Jews no
longer acknowledged the collectivity and
religious Jews would wait forever for
God to act both these forms of exilic
consciousness had to be negated Zionists
success was the work of new Jews who
embodied this negation there can't be
any doubt about the newness though there
were plenty of old Jews in and around
the Zionist movement nor were all the
new Jews heroic pioneers working the
land as in Zionist legend nor were there
all that many of them Zionism was not a
mass
movement it always had a certain elitist
character which derives from the fact
that the negation of an ancient culture
is not a popular cause the vanguard of
new Jews included political activists
and even politicians also soldiers
bureaucrats managers professionals
intellectuals and farmers and workers
what made them new was that they did not
accept rabbinic Authority they were not
deferential to their Gentile Turkish and
British rulers and they refused to defer
their hope for national independence
Akkad Homme had a very precise picture
of how these people would would work
first they would transform themselves
then they would create a spiritual
centre in Palestine and working outward
from the center they would slowly
transform the general culture of exilic
jewelry then slowly again they would
create a political center and ultimately
an independent state but this gradualist
prospect was shattered by the urgencies
of 20th century Jewish life in the event
the vanguard created the state and won
the wars that statehood required long
before the cultural transformation was
completed once the state was established
its first task was the ingathering of
the exiles first the surviving Jews of
Central and Eastern Europe displaced
persons desperate for a place and then
the Jews of North Africa and Mesopotamia
living under threat because of the
eclipses of Empire and the rise of local
nationalisms the ingathering was a great
success hundreds of thousands of
immigrants poured into the new state
it's most dramatic effect however was to
bring home the under gated culture of
the Exile
so what Zionism in the Diaspora had not
accomplished
the new zionist state set out to
accomplish the absorption of immigrants
was designed as a process of cultural
transformation it represented the
continuation of the earlier cultural war
by other means ben-gurion description of
what needed to be done
written before the establishment of the
state is instructive this is ben-gurion
absorption means taking uprooted
impoverished sterile Jewish masses
living parasitically off of an alien
economic body and dependent on others
and introducing them to productive and
creative life in planting them on the
land integrating them into primary
production agriculture and Industry and
handicraft and making them economically
independent and self-sufficient
immigrant absorption was a form of state
action the work of civil servants
teachers social workers and army
instructors as ben-gurion x'v herbs
suggests the process was less persuasive
than coercive it was marked by a kind of
authoritarianism and it was this became
clear only later on bitterly resented it
was also successfully resisted privately
by many of the immigrants and it is now
publicly challenged by a revived and
militant Judaism though important
qualifications are necessary
I can tell a similar story about
Palestinian national liberation in this
case the liberationist militants have
not yet won their battle they are at
this moment the protagonists of a failed
but not a definitively failed political
movement one day there will be a
Palestinian state but the encounter of
secular nationalism with a religious
revival is already well begun and the
surprise of the secularists at the
strength of the rule
forces is not much different in this
case than in my other cases their
inability to found a state no doubt
fueled the religious revival but it
doesn't explain it had they succeeded
the secular nationalists would still
have been challenged by an Islamic
fierceness that they did not foresee the
liberationists leaders in this case
never went to school with their imperial
opponents they did not study in England
and they never attended Israeli
universities but with the critical
exception of Yasser Arafat many of the
earliest leaders of the Palestinian
movement because there were Christians
and then because there were Marxists did
look at their own people from a
significant critical distance militants
like George Habash
and wadi haddad founders of the Popular
Front for the Liberation of Palestine
studied at the American University in
Beirut called themselves Marxist
Leninist
and were brutally critical of
traditional Arab politics it would be
hard to overestimate the importance of
Christian Palestinians like these - in
the early liberation movement and
especially in its most radical and most
radically secularists wing our fight is
harder to figure out than the Marxist
militants of the Popular Front but in
many ways he fits the picture of the
nationalist leader that I sketched in
the first of these lectures born in
Egypt to parents who left Palestine in
1927 well before the Nakba of 48 he came
to lead a people whose formative
experience he did not share as one of
his biographers writes he had no
childhood home in the lost homeland no
plot of land which became the possession
of someone else no close relatives who
were transformed into destitute
Fuji's for many years he worked as an
engineer in Kuwait and it was there that
Fatah was founded the name is an acronym
but the word means conquering or victory
and it is often used to describe the
early years of Islamic expansion our
thought according to all his biographers
was a believing Muslim and by no means a
Marxist the organization he founded
however was secular and nationalist in
character inspired more by the Algerian
FLN and the writings of Franz fanon than
by the Quran to the true believers of
Hamas Arafat was a typical secularist
committed to the establishment of a
national state and not in Islamic state
his successors are no different enemies
therefore who must be replaced let me
return for a moment to the general
version of the story many successful
national liberation movements produced
without intending to an underground
culture a secret traditionalism
nourished by memory carried by the
family sustained in religious
conventicle Zanden lifecycle ceremonies
the protagonists of this culture pose as
citizens of the new state they attended
schools they serve or some of them serve
in its army vote in in its elections
accept the benefits it provides without
ever allowing themselves to be
refashioned in its image they don't
become the new men and women that
ben-gurion and fennan celebrated they
don't become modern secular liberal
democratic citizens and their first
allegiance isn't to the nation-state but
to something more like the traditional
pre-state community and after a time
when national liberation has receded in
memory the traditionalist staged a
counter-revolution
thus the rise of Islamic radicalism in
Algeria and in Palestine and of Hindutva
in India their resurgence is a great
shock to the national liberation elites
who had grown complacent about the
victory of newness at the same time
however the traditionalists are not
really as close in spirit or creed to
their ancestors as they'd like to think
they may not be liberated but they are
changed by the experience of liberation
often in ways they themselves don't
understand so the outcome of the
counter-revolution is uncertain in any
case it lies beyond my reach here in
these lectures for the Indian Israeli
and Algerian stories are still
unfinished the return of the negated
brings with it a militantly religious
nationalism which has radically altered
the politics of all three countries and
of Palestine - but hasn't yet
overwhelmed or defeated the
liberationist project the return of the
negated is a general phenomenon but it's
also peculiar to each case so let me
focus again on the Israeli peculiar well
on the exact ace with its peculiarities
when exilic jewelry comes home it brings
with it a characteristic politics this
may be concealed for a time behind a
facade of conventional citizen like
behavior but it is possible nonetheless
to describe its basic features I have to
note at this point that I'm not
discussing here the arrival of the
Soviet Jews in Israel who had been
modernized and secularized by communists
not by Zionists and who don't fit neatly
into my schematic account the politics
of religious especially of Ulker
religious Jews in Israel follows from
the experience of Exile and is obviously
more closely continuous with that
experience than Zionism is
many of Israel's Jewish citizens do not
really think of the state as their own
they may be fierce nationalists but they
don't have the sense that citizens are
supposed to have of being responsible
for the whole they don't recognize a
good that is common to themselves and
all other Israelis they retain a view of
the state characteristic of a stateless
people always Outsiders always
vulnerable they are political
opportunists seeking to seize whatever
benefits the state provides and escape
its burdens exactly as they did with
better reason in Czarist Russia the
fellowship of democratic citizens and
the freewheeling debates of democratic
politics are largely alien to them they
participate in an older fellowship
Zionism for them as I'm nan Rubinstein
has written is not a return to the
family of Nations but it's diametric
opposite a new polarization between the
Jews and the Gentiles of the earth the
arab-israeli conflict gives this
polarization a special force but the
view is general all the others are
hostile and threatening the whole world
is on one side and we are on the other
wrote an Orthodox rabbi in the 1970s in
what is really an astonishing
misrepresentation of the condition of
his country other nasaan this view is
always closed and always dangerous it
includes the world of secular Jewish
enlightenment as well as the world of
the Gentiles but all this represents
only one side of exilic political
consciousness the side of deference fear
and resentment the other side is
represented is what I called
millennialism in my first lecture the
other side is represented among the Jews
by the figure of the Messiah whose
coming was in the long years of the
exile
indefinitely deferred the insistence
that one must wait for the Messiah and
the rabbinic ban on forcing the end
obviously support the political culture
of passivity on the other hand the
abiding certainty that he will one day
come the intermittent unforeseen
inexplicable intensification of
expectancy the appearance of false
prophets and messianic pretenders all
these suggests a deep dissatisfaction
with that culture messianism is
simultaneously a comforting fantasy and
a great disruptive force secular Zion is
exploited this force even claimed
sometimes to embody it but in fact they
naturalized that they came to they made
messianism into hard work and redemption
into a gradual process of acquisition
and renewal another dunam another goat
but once the mundane work was done and
religious Jews beheld the state
especially the state as it was in that
ominously magical moment of 1967
triumphant over its enemies many of them
decided that they that they did indeed
live in messianic times or better on the
very brink of messianic times national
liberation had brought them this far but
could go no further
now the Messiah waited only for the zeal
of the faithful to express itself in
political life like the Zionist pioneers
the faithful would settle the land but
they would act in fulfillment of divine
command not of secular ideology and they
would live in accordance with divine law
and then the glorious days would begin
fundamentalist enthusiasm is the most
visible and frightening version of the
Jewish counter-revolution it enacts the
old exilic understanding that redemption
is the only alternative to exile but it
is also at the same time a radically new
politics it lays claim to state power it
exalts military force both of which
excellent off' ID with the other as many
ultra-orthodox jews still do but
messianism in modern israel as in the
history of the exile is likely to have a
short life it is infinitely susceptible
to disappointment disillusion and new
postponements and post 67 jewish
messianism has already I think begun to
fade the real challenge to Zionist
liberation comes from a strange and as
contemporary Israeli politics suggests
only partially consummated merger of
messianic militancy with the coming out
and the rising assertiveness of the
traditional culture since this was a
culture born in statelessness its
political enactment in an actual state
is often strident confused and
contradictory if protagonists are at
once fearful of the non-jewish world and
hostile to it anxious and aggressive
they are opportunistically committed to
the state ret reliant on its military
strength eager to use its coercive power
on their own behalf but they are quick
to deny the legitimacy of the state's
elected and even more its judicial
representatives whenever they don't like
official policies they are nationalists
with a ghetto mentality parochial
besieged and belligerent it's very hard
to figure out who benefits from this
kind of nationalism Marxist analysis
isn't of much help in this case as I
suggested yesterday it might be in the
Indian case certainly Israeli
capitalists do not benefit from this
religious zealot Rhee the rabbi's
benefit their authority is enhanced and
right-wing populist politicians find new
opportunities the post 67 settlers
obviously benefit
at least in the short run but they are
the creation of gsella tree not its
cause no one else's position is likely
to be improved or strengthened can
Jewish zealots and traditionalists
exercise effective power in the modern
world or sustain a modern economy or
negotiate with Israel's neighbors or
find a way to peace with the
Palestinians can they govern justly in a
state that includes large numbers of
non-jews and larger numbers of
non-believing Jews my own view is that
these questions cannot be successfully
answered from a position of
traditionalist militancy ultimately the
counter-revolution will fail though the
militants may play significant roles in
present and future governments a modern
state with anti-modern ministers a
formula for trouble how is such a thing
possible given the success of national
liberation in fact Zionist responses to
the eruption of messianism and the
return of traditionalism have been
surprisingly weak the chief intellectual
reason for the weakness there are also
political reasons is the double failure
of cultural negation on the one hand the
old religious culture was not overcome
on the other hand the new secular
culture isn't thick or robust enough to
sustain itself by itself trying to
explain the return to pre emancipation
days his phrase the literary and social
critic our own Megan says simply every
vacuum must fill up that isn't really
fair since Zionists writers and
activists did a great deal to fill the
cultural space left by the negation of
the Exile the new culture was partly a
reflection of the history of the
movement itself but it also reached back
to the Bible and outward to 19th and
20th century liberationists I
geologies Arthur Hertzberg has said of
Zionism that it's ultimate values
derived from the general European milieu
but it nonetheless produced its own
ideas and institutions heroes and
holidays ceremonies and celebrations
songs and dances all this was very
powerful for a couple of generations it
hasn't had much staying power beyond
that however the social reproduction of
secular Zionism has faltered badly in
the last few decades
and mega ads claim that there isn't
anything there has acquired greater
currency than it deserves but if a
vacuum doesn't exist there is as I
suggested yesterday a thinness in the
cultural air and there may be a
connection between that thinness and the
radical negation with which Zionism
began one important consequence of
radical negation is the force of the
secular religious dichotomy in Israel
today secular describes the people for
whom the Exile has indeed been negated
religious those for whom it definitely
hasn't been who sustained the old
culture in the new state it seems that
there are no middle terms no compromised
versions of negation no liberalized
versions of the old religion perhaps
Zionist bibletump
was intended as a kind of synthesis of
the religion of the ancient Israelites
though not of exilic Judaism with modern
secularists ideology the connections
forged through historical study
archaeology exploration of the land
secular adaptations of biblical holidays
and much else but there was something
artificial in all that given the actual
history of the Jews the leap to the
Bible garum Sholem argued in a 1970
interview is purely fictitious the Bible
being a reality that
does not exist today in any case the
leap was only to the most politically
useful biblical texts and it invited
counter leaps to different texts there
is a line in Shakespeare's Merchant of
Venice about this sort of thing that
resonates with recent Israeli experience
the devil can cite scripture for his
purpose of course the Bible is a Jewish
text and a critical engagement with it
could and sometimes did produce
interesting arguments but I want to
suggest an alternative to this Zionist
search for a useful past I don't do this
with any confidence that the alternative
could have been realized in the history
that I've just described but it might
still have some relevance for the future
what National Liberation required was a
critical engagement with the post
biblical Jewish tradition that is with
Judaism itself
Sholem argues that Zionism was
constituted from its beginning by a
dialectic of rebellion and continuity
the rebellion takes the form of secular
negation the continuity is embodied in
traditional Judaism these terms are
certainly contradictory but they haven't
been brought into a dialectical relation
that is a relation in which each
influences the other and the two are
transformed in some interactive way what
sorts of moves from each of the two
sides might make their interaction
possible I can speak only from the side
of secular rebellion and try to answer
as it were one half of that question how
might a critical engagement with the
tradition strengthen liberationists
culture in the fourth and last of these
lectures I will lay out a tentative
response to that question and I will
also suggest that the question has close
analogues in contemporary Indian debates
about the future of Nehru
Veon secularism but before that I need
to deal with Marxist and post-colonial
critics who deny that there is a paradox
of national liberation who insists that
the question at which I have just
arrived is not the right question and
who argued that the strengthening of
Zionists culture or Nehru V and
secularism is not a desirable goal I'll
take up that line of criticism in my
next lecture
yes
you